hi everybody my name is Doug I'm a
researcher at Google on the Google brain
team and I'm going to talk to you about
some work that we're doing on trying to
use generative models to make new things
and the context for this connects I
think very nicely with with a Nima's
talk which I thought was was really
fantastic and I kind of want to put in
context the the amazing work that Amazon
is doing at MX net and I think the
Facebook folks with with Pi torch and
and some of the work that's happening
I'm tensorflow at Google and that's to
rewind back to the year 2000 some of you
maybe weren't even out of elementary
school I was a postdoc in Switzerland
with a guy named jurgen schmidhuber and
I was working on this crazy model that
no one had heard of called Ellis TM long
short-term memory and I was actually
turned to get it to compose music and so
if you think of yourself in 2000 that's
17 long years ago the way that we worked
was by hacking lots of C++ code and so
Felix Pierce who was the person that
invented the forget gave in LST M he had
his implementation in C++ and I had to
have my implementation in C++ and then
this other crazy guy this young grad
student named Alex graves came along and
he had to have his version in C++
because I didn't want to use mine I
didn't want to use Felix's and so you
have this idea okay I want to try
something new right well it's like it's
a lot of work right because you you you
have to write a bunch of new code and I
saw something happen about 10 years ago
at a place called university of montreal
where i was a professor working in deep
learning in music and some of the guys
in the lab thought that it would be cool
to try to automate some of this and so
they built out something called piano
and I thought fionna was crazy partially
because it made me jealous so I saw them
working and I genuinely mean that it's
like watching my daughter not want to
learn how to drive a stick shift a
manual transmission like you should have
to do that right and I felt like these
students should have to write 50,000
lines of code
but it turns out what I saw happening
even ten years ago I think I think the
key was automatic differentiation it
wasn't just linear algebra you had to
have linear algebra but you also needed
automatic differentiation is that now
it's almost like jazz improv that was
the term that came to mind for me
thinking about music at the time it's
like they could just like decide to
change out that continent for an RNN or
they could decide to you know change the
architecture to be able to build these
huge graphs that Anna Mae was talking
about and this project that I'm going to
talk about now which is called magenta
actually stems from asking the question
what can we do next
now that we have these wonderful tools
what are some new things that we can try
that we haven't been able to do before
and for me my personal viewpoint is that
you know supervised learning over over
high dimensional data has been explored
and that I'm not going to add much to
the table by exploring it more but then
we have other directions to go in
including reinforcement learning
unsupervised learning others forms of
density estimation and of course things
that none of us have dreamt of where we
might go next and so for me I started
talking about moving on to caring about
generative models models that can
generate new instances of the data upon
which they're trained and I think this
is you know one direction to go in and
so the rest of this talk is going to be
about that it's going to be about kind
of the thought process that might lead
you to caring about getting deep
learning models and reinforcement
learning models to do things like
generate new text make music and maybe
make art and when I talk about it in the
context of trying to connect with
artists and musicians because I think
connecting with the creative community
especially the creative coding community
is going to be crucial if we're going to
use
generative models for something more
than then some of the things we're using
before now so let's start with some some
of the at least for me some I think some
important important models one of them
is this idea that we can transform
language from one transform like
language in English from sorry we can
translate it's all I wanted to say
and I also thought it was pretty cute
that we could do things like translate
into multiple languages by just
prepending a token that said what
language we're going to learn a kind of
inter lingua and and learn some things
about what's general across languages
that's all fine but it also gives rise
to some new products and I think here is
where I'm starting to think about
generative models so we have this idea
that we can improve translation but not
only can we improve translation of the
server room but like on your device you
now have a much better translation
giving rise to I think a whole family of
products that maybe won't make sense to
me but might make sense to my kids and I
also just as an aside want to point out
that the translation that we're seeing
it's not just Google this is a Google
example but using deep learning for
translation has really it's been a game
changer in terms of expressivity ok so
if we look at the old translation from
phrase based machines we see this last
sentence of Hemingway's snows of
Kilimanjaro being translated and back
translated from Japanese whether the
leopard had what the demanded at that
altitude there is no that nobody
explained moving towards no one can
explain what leopard was seeking at that
altitude and it just dropped the the and
so what I would do I'm going to back up
a slide the gains that we see compared
to the previous systems in blue and the
green is the game that we saw from using
neural networks for this problem start
to become very close to what humans can
do in yellow on these language pairs
you'll note that not all language pairs
are equally easy it's harder to
translate back and forth from Chinese
and English than it is to Chinese and
English and Spanish
I think that's intuitive but that even
these gains the the green that we gained
moved us in terms of expressivity a long
long long way and it's that expressivity
that we need if we're going to care
about using these models for generative
purposes the other this was a Google
effort came out of Google brain how many
of you have seen smart reply how many of
you are repelled by smart reply you
think it's the worst thing that could
happen ok that's ok it's ok
how many of you actually think it's cool
okay more of us is the techno this is
this is a techno happy crowd I've given
this talk in other places and many many
many more people were repelled by the
idea okay so let's talk about generative
models this is actually not a generative
model this is picking phrases that were
pre composed okay but let's just move to
a world just as a thought experiment
because I'm the fun you know this is
just an aside for you all right what
what happens when we can actually use
deep nuts to compose a whole paragraph
and we give you an interface that maybe
gives you a few suggestions but that
suggestion actually is multiple
sentences and then we train and we get
better and by we I don't mean Google I
mean we as a research community I have
no idea where this is gonna come from
okay now I'm already thinking of some of
the side effects one of them is email
the text in an email and it won't be an
email because like I have kids no one
uses email anymore except us right so
it'll be some other form but I'm like
remember like at some age it was when
word processors came along to be polite
to your grandmother
you'd handwrite the thank you note and I
think will happen is we'll handwrite the
email right because because that will
show respect for someone in a way like
I'm not gonna let my you know I'm not
gonna let software generate my response
to you right because this is a love
letter or this is a thank-you note so
this one I'm gonna write by myself
right and then and then you have the the
the game theoretical version of that
which is the the boy or girl you're
trying to court says you didn't really
write that you know yeah no I did really
I wrote the whole thing by myself so so
there's there's a lot of directions this
isn't go and in terms of generative
models and so this was the thinking that
led to created this project about really
about two years ago thinking can we can
we use deep learning to create some new
things that mean something and it says
right there that we're gonna make music
and art using machine learning though in
some sense it's a bit of a falsehood
because as you'll see from the rest of
the talk it's not that interesting to
just push a button and watch machines
make art right that sort of sort of
skips the whole point of what art is for
which is I think it's some level
communication right and so we'll put
that aside we left that that's the title
I'm not going to change the website but
I'm really I think what belies this
is getting back to smart reply things
like watching these are my kids this is
Sam and Olivia and they're in Japan and
they're very adventurous eaters they
actually basically ate everything that
we could find there's a blast this was
last last Christmas but you'll note and
these were not staged Sam's phone is
right there on the counter with him and
I was picking up our train tickets in
Tokyo and they're laughing at something
on their phone and and what I'm watching
these kids do is actually really live
their lives through these mobile devices
and and they're living them in a way
that is not I think just kind of re
recapitulate in the way that we lived
our lives with whatever your generation
is with word processors or email or
nothing and so if you put yourself in
the mind mindset of what we're doing
with machine learning and how far we've
come
I thought it was very interesting to put
myself in the shoes of the grad students
at University of Montreal who are
developing Fano which I thought was
silly you know and to say okay wait a
minute these kids are using things like
snapchat right how many people here use
snapchat a linear correlation between
how old you are and whether or not you
use that chat it turns out if you're not
familiar with snapchat it actually helps
you tell a story it does it in very
simple ways it might do something as
simple as put a little some whiskers and
give you a little cat cat face or it
might actually allow you to frame a
narrative and a little small way and
what I noticed these kids doing is
absolutely seamlessly without any
assumptions about how this really should
work or does work just using snapchat to
communicate right using it to tell their
stories and so I think in my mind
there's a very very possible future
where we're using real machine learning
and real generative models to generate
content but we're allowing users to
shape that so we're basically building
tools that themselves are generative and
intelligent but they're helping us
communicate okay so now we're going to
dive into that's that's the philosophy
101 of magenta now I'm going to talk
about two or three projects and I'm
going to focus on a couple of machine
learning techniques this isn't a
terribly technical talk but it is
actually quite technical work despite
the pictures of bears and things like
that so the first project I'm going to
talk about takes advantage of a game
came out of Creative Lab at Google New
York called quick-draw who's familiar
with quick-draw okay so if you're not
it's basically playing pictionary
against a machine learning algorithm and
as you draw you're told what to draw
draw a bear and as you draw the Miss the
your laptop is actually shouting at you
it's really horrible it's like oh it's a
bear no it's a truck no it's it's really
very distracting and you have twenty
seconds and so what we have it turns out
our almost a billion drawings it's a big
number we don't need that many as it
turns out drawn in less than twenty
seconds while being shouted at by a
computer so this is these are the raw
materials of art right here and what we
decided to do the primary research on
research around this was David ha who
did some similar work in the past with
kanji with Japanese Chinese characters
what we're gonna do is we're gonna try
to learn to draw and I focus on drawing
here not pixels because it gives us a
very different space in which to work so
we stored the actual strokes that the
users drew as they were trying to draw
the cat and what we're going to do is
we're going to try to try to encode that
information into some sort of auto
regressive model or auto encoder and
then we're going to decode it and we're
going to get back a cat that's nice and
because we're smart machine learning
researchers this bottleneck is going to
be added so that the Z or Z where we're
storing our information in the latent
space is actually constrained otherwise
it just memorizes cats and we all know
it's boring to memorize and so we're
going to talk about a couple of aspects
of Zed so one of them is that it's
compressed and so how many of you
noticed that the the drawing on the left
and the drawing on the right are
different right so this is real data the
you give the the trained model a cat
with five whiskers and it gives you back
a cat with six whiskers and like that's
already in my mind kind of interesting
right
obviously there's an easy explanation
for that there's some mode and the data
that has faces of cats and if you look
at the strokes which are actually just
Delta X Delta Y that's the way the data
is represented just Delta X Delta Y
where did the pen move was the pen
picked up into the did the drawing stop
so it's very simple data representation
somehow there's a mode in this data
where you tend to draw that six whisker
and so the model does that it's a form
of underfitting but it's also I think
kind of interesting if we move forward
and we start to sample from a model like
this what we see is that the model does
a pretty good job of storing kind of
what you would consider reasonable
drawings this is this is a this is
trained on the yoga class okay and these
are unconditional samples from from yoga
and we can turn up the temperature so
that we can you know we sort of flatten
out the softmax probability density so
we're likely to sample from less
probable spaces of the model and hot
yoga is more dangerous than cold yoga it
really is as I said they're kind of
funny right like you really like you
could do the ones on the top we all
could probably take a stretch break and
do that but we're not going to do the
ones on the bottom and and one thing I
can point out is is these this is one of
the technical bits in the talk we'll
come back to a second time these
drawings are these are unconditionally
sampled from the model okay and they all
make sense right you can we can generate
a million of these and grab one and it
will make sense and one reason it makes
sense
is that the the Z that we build is is
trained so that if you if you roll the
dice
now the dice that we have instead of
having one die let's say that we have
like a hundred dimensional Z right we're
gonna roll a hundred dice right one for
each dimension in Z okay in the doctor
and those dice are going to be couching
they're not going to be uniform they're
gonna be Gaussian right so what's going
to happen is we're going to treat each
of the each of the dimensions of our
embedding space as being spread out over
a Gaussian over a bell curve okay so
that when we roll the dice we get
something meaningful okay so the way
we're going to achieve that some of you
have probably already jumped ahead and
some of you don't know this yield as
well we're going to actually not just
Train Z to reproduce cat drawings we're
going to also add an additional cost
which trains Z to try to act like a
random number generator in Gaussian it's
kind of weird because if
you ask Z to be a random number
generator it doesn't get to store any
information I mean you don't want to
train completely on that but yet if you
ask the model to just reproduce cat
drawings it might give you an embedding
space where if you sample from it
certain areas of that sampled space
don't make any sense right and so this
is called the variational model and it
involves training on two costs one of
them being reconstruction l2 cost on the
drawing and the other one is KL
divergence against Gaussian noise so you
basically have this mixture of saying
I'm gonna let you store information but
I'm gonna make you store that
information in such a way that I can
generate from it and there's a whole
family of techniques that I grouped
together as being making models able to
generate in a way that makes sense I'm
not gonna have time to touch on all of
them but if you want a laundry list
other things would involve having a
counterfeit detector that forces the
model to try to generate really
realistic versions of what it's
generating called a generative
adversarial Network you might use
reinforcement learning to add some sort
of structural cost that forces the
network to do something that it wouldn't
otherwise do these are all ways to force
the model to do something more
interesting than just minimize sort of
l2 distance the Euclidean distance / /
strokes or / pixels or / whatever and
that's what gives us this property of
being able to sample from the model now
why do I do this in the first place
we're going to switch gears for a second
because this model is living in the
space of strokes and because it's
trained on a variational loss it can
kind of pick up where you left off so
what David is doing here is he's drawing
a mosquito and as he's drawing it we
have nine versions we were sampling from
the model nine times to complete that
mosquito drawing and remember we also
have this network predicting end of
drawing so if it it will stop when it
thinks it's ready if you're curious the
encoders and decoders are both recurrent
neural networks the decoder also uses a
mixture of gaussians to predict the XY
dimensions this is kind of cool
the other the other thing I would point
out is that because we're living in such
a space we're getting this kind of
regularization but that you can perhaps
use this kind of reg
for artistic means right if you look at
an artist or a person putting in rather
normal things like I think the first
column looks like pretty straightforward
drawings of cats
you're gonna more let's get them back
but if you put in an eight-legged Pig
you're gonna get back a four-legged Pig
and I think I think my favorite and I
think this is suggestive if if you have
a model for for just four pigs and you
give it a truck right it gives you a
truck Pig right and and I like it that
you're laughing I think it's great that
it's funny remember these were just
drawings that were trained in this game
where you had twenty seconds right but
even even with with that kind of data if
you take some care you can build out
these these kind of really cool effects
right and so I want you to think about
what would happen if you had artists
actually trying really hard you know you
have an artist who's trying to put her
thoughts into a model like this right
giving it a hundred really cool drawings
and then starting to sample from the
model and looking at the possible
futures that could come from being able
to expand and the nice thing about that
is if it's the artists art you know the
expansions are just another extension of
that art so it's not really the machine
doing the hard work incidentally it's
not always interesting if you give the
cat class a toothbrush it doesn't really
give you back a cat or a toothbrush at
the bottom there and no three odd cats
no chakra okay and this is my last one I
love this so this is the raine class it
turns out if you draw a cloud people
always drew rain after the clouds so you
can just kind of make it rain and do
this live is fun you just as soon as you
start the cloud drawing it it does that
for you okay oh and you should change
the shape of the drops I usually do
these live but I wanted to to make sure
it save time for something else okay so
the closing thought on this art stuff is
yeah we've we're just scratching the
surface you do kind of a variational
model using kind of well-known encoders
and decoders there's some nice tricks to
keep these models from overfitting but
mostly what I think it is is just trying
out new things in the space of
generative models I don't expect anybody
to go home and play with skin this is
all an open source and on the present
like play with sketch RNN and like you
know like put on your head and your your
smock and your easel and be like this is
art but I also want you to leave
thinking wait this is actually a very
interesting direction for us to go and
now I'm going to switch to music and
some similar work and I hope you'll find
evocative the work that I was doing with
jurgen schmidhuber back in the day was
focused on trying to take auto
regressive models specifically LST m and
and to see if we could write music with
LST m by predicting the next note and
there was actually a very serious
question behind this which is ken LST M
which is you know a very complicated and
amical system in principle able to
capture a long term structure can it
actually capture the kind of structure
that we see in music which is repeating
and has it has strong temporal
constraints okay so it's actually quite
an interesting time series to work with
if what you're looking at are models
that can learn long term structure and
it turns out that everybody else's work
except mine wasn't very good but my work
in 2000 was really really good
2002 read the paper and it's great no it
was actually kind of boring wandering
blues and we've recently and the magenta
team this work was this work is also up
on our blog at Chico magenta
I think we've we've we've moved towards
much much more interesting music using
roughly the same approach but we didn't
really change machine learning what we
did was we thought more carefully about
how to match data to to process and I
think if you start caring about
generative models you have to care as
much about where the data is coming from
and what you want to do with the data as
you care about the actual did I use a
rel uu or how many layers did I put in
my model and so what we did I'll back
this up we moved from caring about
musical scores to caring about musical
performances and we were lucky enough to
get a number of expert pianists playing
in a piano competition Yamaha runs these
a piano competitions and they capture
the data on a disc live er reproducing
pianos and they put that data out for
everyone you all it's all out there on
the web to use with a great license to
play around and do research with it and
so now what we have is something looks
like a piano roll like this it's not
aligned to a score anymore there is a
score the score was being played but all
that's slowing down and speeding up that
you see
the expert pianists doing that's in the
data as well and it turns out that's
crucial because it gives us a lot more
variance to work with and keeps us from
overfitting and it makes these models
much less brittle we can generate much
more interesting music by by by
generating from performances of these
scores than we can from the scores
themselves and so what we do the the
model itself is is there's more to it
than is in this graph I mean we're using
attentional mechanisms and a lot of
other kind of modern machine learning
but fundamentally it's an auto regressor
it's LST m and it's predicting a single
softmax this says should I turn a note
on should I change note velocity should
I turn a note off or should I advance
the tape should I advance in time by as
much as little as a millisecond okay and
so what we get are performances with
velocities and with with with the
contraction and dilation of time and
what you'll hear next are some
unconditional samples from this model so
this is work in progress
this isn't conditioned on any
performance this is just rolling the
dice again and starting off from some
starting point and playing I hope you'll
agree that they're rather evocative
pieces of music
[Music]
and it would have gone on forever stop
there's one to give you an idea of the
variants let's hear a second one
[Music]
and it's your third one
so I don't okay honest vote who's like
now and there's like okay these are kind
of interesting okay good that's great I
think they are too I think there's a lot
missing and let's be let's be humble
here let's just look from a bird's eye
view this is a Chopin's a tune and E
major up above and these are a few of
the neural network performances
visualized the same way as a piano roll
where time rolls horizontal then you can
see there's a massive amount of
structure happening in a piece of music
composed by a music expert that we're
not getting to it we're not even close
but I feel like we're getting these
evocative short term bursts this is up
there's a really kind of fun demo you
can play with on our blog that in
actually in deep learning is so on your
browser will run this model and you can
play with a few conditioning variables
and I think of it like wind chimes more
than music but it's kind of fun to play
with so what does this model do well
let's compare it to the the sketch
Arnett model with the cats
we don't have cats we have music and so
here's the proposed encoder pair with
the decoder and some variational
embedding it turns out this model is
really just the LS TM network so if you
want to think about it in terms of auto
auto encoders it's really just taking in
MIDI and pushing out MIDI and decoding
it through an LS TM so there's a lot of
work to be done
where we want to be is actually here we
really do want to have some encoder of
music
the problem is music is variable length
and we can't hope to fit in our Zi the
entire piece of music that doesn't make
sense so we need to think of ways to
chunk this and move towards more
hierarchical models and we've we've got
some preliminary work that I'm going to
show you this hasn't been published even
on our blog yet the basic idea is to
have AZ but that Z's job is only to
store a measure of music right only only
a little bit a bar and then we're gonna
have to have we'll need two decoders
we'll need to decode a measure of music
but we need to chain that together and
be able to decode multiple measures of
music so that we get something coherent
and if we can train these models right
what we should be able to do is actually
generate some coherent long-term
structure
and this is what the whole graph looks
like we're at the top it's a little bit
complicated but those are the green
boxes are measures and they're
independent individually sequentially
being encoded into our auto encoder and
then decoded as as as measures that are
then pushed back to decode it as phrases
that are then pushed back down as
measures okay well when I could have
time to dig into that with the time wow
that came fast sorry so but so Adam
Roberts trained on music where he had a
baseline and he had a lead and drums and
they're all being pushed through the
encoder and they're all being stored in
this latent space and then there are
three separate decoders one decoders for
drums one decoders for bass and ones for
lead now this is gonna sound like pop
music we should be listening for it does
it actually sound coherent because no
one's really been able to make coherent
you know traditionally generated music
like this maybe you could control the
volume a little bit from the back in
case it's too loud
[Music]
little bridge at the end so I know it's
kind of interesting and come back to
that we're running out of time so I also
want to mention one other benefit of
living in this embedding space is the
last thing I'll have time for is that
just at the shape of a measure and the
same way that we can move around the
embedding space for drawings we can move
around for four simple measures of music
so we're gonna here as a starting
measure and an ending measure and then
we're gonna like more move our way
through linearly a spherically linearly
through through through try to get from
one to the other so that's thing a
[Music]
that's then B to embeddings
I can do that
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah that was pretty cool let's shout
out to Adam Roberts for that and it's
it's not easy to get from point A to
point B in an embedding space and have
it make sense and I think all of those
made some musical sense I'm out of time
we're not their successful musical
instruments even musical tools as simple
as drum machines and guitar pedals are
super hard to build we've built a few
tools but we haven't really managed to
allow musicians to express themselves
with these nor artists so we've got a
ton of work to do please check out our
blog this is also on a github there's a
bunch of open source code out there and
we have a lot more coming at nips as
part of a creativity and design workshop
apologies for going over a couple
minutes thank you all very much for for
your attention
[Applause]